alors que les laboratoires sont
surchargées que les chiffres du coït 19
sont à la hausse dans la région ile de
france on apprend aujourd'hui que 20
centres de dépistages vont s'ouvrir
prochainement dans la région est
déployée par la rs ces sites seront
capables de réaliser dix mille
prélèvements par jour ils seront ouverts
jusqu'à la fin de l'hiver et seront
répartis dans les huit départements
franciliens et les emplacements exacts
ne sont pas encore connues et les
personnes pourront se rendre sur place
sans rendez vous de 8 heures à 19 heures
des plages horaires réservées pour les
cas asymptomatiques lé dispositif vient
compléter les 591 points de prélèvement
déjà installés dans la région